[Musique]
et bonjour à tous bienvenue sur la page
Facebook de TV 78 c'est le jour J le
lancement du Big tour à Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines nous sommes le mardi 20
septembre et pour parler du Big tour un
événement co-organisé par BPI France et
50 ans Yvelines nous sommes avec Patrice
bégaye le directeur exécutif de BPI
France Bonjour bonjour à vous alors vous
êtes même le fondateur du Big tour alors
là on est dans les coulisses il y a une
émission qui va commencer à 9h c'est
vivre ta ville ça fait un moment déjà
que vous faites le tour de France pour
aller à la rencontre des entrepreneurs
français là c'est la dernière étape
aujourd'hui oui on fait le tour de
France comme vous dites c'est le
festival les entrepreneurs l'innovation
et l'emploi nous aurons reçu sur ce
plateau ici
1200 invités cette tournée rendez-vous
compte 30 étapes un peu plus de 40
invités par étape
là vous le savez vous êtes sur le
deuxième pôle économique d'Île-de-France
c'est 50 ans en Yvelines terre
d'innovation il y a des entreprises dans
tous les secteurs d'activité
aéronautique automobile
cybersécurité aussi là tout à l'heure
vous allez avoir autour de votre plateau
vous allez avoir Jean-Michel fourgon le
président de l'agglomération de 50 ans
et puis un invité d'honneur aussi le
ministre de l'Économie Bruno Le Maire
oui absolument nous avons monté cette
opération cette dernière étape
métropolitaine c'est bien le dire avec
Jean-Michel fourgousse et puis également
toutes les communes du 78 mais également
du département mais de la région toute
la région Île-de-France avec Valérie
Pécresse et puis nos partenaires du
Medef de la CPME dcci tout le monde est
très très mobilisé nous avons 300 médias
qui sont sur cette événement en 300
partenaires toutes les marques de la
presque régionale les télévisions
locales dont vous faites partie parce
que c'est en fait ça les énergies
créatrices sont dans le territoire et
les médias comme les votes sont très
importants pour du doigt justement tous
les secteurs qui recrutent et ils sont
nombreux en France très nombreux quels
sont les objectifs quand vous avez
imaginé cet événement
quel était imaginé
la création de cet événement l'objectif
c'était d'abord de d'avoir plus
d'entrepreneurs doubler le nombre
d'entrepreneur en France plus de femmes
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai nommé
et maintenant 3 ans Barbara pas patient
pour s'occuper de cette tournée là plus
de jeunes c'est pour ça qu'on a une
équipe de 120 personnes qui soient
technicien qui soit dans l'audiovisuel
qui soit au niveau des artistes vous
voyez là en train de préparer par
exemple l'émission Alix benezek qui va
m'accompagner la comédienne et artiste
on va recevoir aussi tout à l'heure
Angelo gopé le patron de la nation
l'homme qui fait un concert toutes les 5
minutes dans le monde YouTube Coldplay
Ed Sheeran ça il va venir en avion
exprès pour cette dernière avec nous et
puis vous l'avez dit le ministre de
l'Économie des Finances on pouvait pas
mieux terminer parce que je vais vous
dire ce qu'a fait l'état durant ces
périodes de pandémie était absolument
exceptionnelles en partenariat avec les
régions avec les départements avec les
villes avec les entrepreneurs en fait la
force de la France c'est son équipe
c'est l'équipe de France de
l'entrepreneuriat alors émission à
suivre à partir de 9 heures sur la page
Youtube de BPI France et puis aussi sur
l'antenne de tv78 et ensuite à midi vous
inaugurez le village BPI France alors ça
se passe sur le parking à l'arrière du
vélo drone il y a deux parties en fait
il y a une partie où on peut rencontrer
les entrepreneurs de 50 ans en Yvelines
sur le parvis du vélo drone voir
différentes innovations c'est ça oui
alors il y a trois parties même si je
peux me permettre il y a à la fois toute
la partie des entrepreneurs locaux etc
qui sont là il y a le grand village du
Big tour sur l'innovation etc et puis à
l'intérieur du Vélodrome il y a ce
fameux job dating n'oubliez pas
2500 offres d'emploi 3000 rendez-vous on
a dit qu'on allait faire la métamorphose
de l'industrie on l'a fait parce que
aujourd'hui l'industrie et il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises industrielles ici
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines sur l'agglo
l'industrie c'est le lieu où aller
bosser je vais vous dire aujourd'hui
tout ce qui touche à l'intelligence
artificielle on produit Connect et tout
ça c'est l'avenir des 20 30 prochaines
années donc je le dis à tous les jeunes
et au moins jeunes allez-y l'industrie
allons aux enfants de l'industrie
on aujourd'hui on va pouvoir trouver un
emploi ici on va pouvoir trouver les
conseils pour entreprendre c'est ça tout
c'est à dire vous allez voir en face de
vous des créateurs d'entreprise comment
ils ont fait des start-up comment elles
ont démarré des TPE comment elles vivent
avec leurs employés les PME pareil les
ETI les entreprises de taille
intermédiaires juste après la PME juste
avant le grand groupe et puis tous ces
grands groupes qui sont là qui nous
accompagnent sur cette tournée grâce à
eux on a pu faire cette tournée grâce à
différents maires on a pu faire cette
tournée grâce aux régions grâce à la
France je reviens là-dessus le festival
des entrepreneurs c'est le festival de
la métamorphose de la France dernière
question sur 50 ans en Yvelines votre
regard sur ce territoire un territoire
qui fait partie du cluster de Paris
sacré en fait j'aime pas le mot cluster
parce que ça nous rappelle des choses
mais ça veut dire aujourd'hui quand vous
l'utilisez dans vos mots vous avez
raison de le dire parce que on
dédramatise la chose aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup de chance parce que on a des
entrepreneurs aujourd'hui qui voient
loin et en même temps j'ai l'habitude de
dire en fait ils ont un point GPS loin
pour amener leurs équipes et puis ils
ont un tableur Excel pour savoir compter
mais c'est un peu ce qu'on a fait et
permettez-moi juste de remercier les 120
personnes qui depuis le 5 mars et jusque
dans l'étape que nous aurons dans les
outre-mer on suivit cette équipe sur le
terrain une fois de plus c'est le
terrain qui fait les choses et puis vous
dire que sur chacune des étapes nous
avons recruté pour la sécurité pour les
hôtesses sans personne supplémentaires
faites le calcul 100 personnes x 30
étapes c'est 3000 personnes qu'on a pu
faire travailler autour du Big tour en
plus du curtime de ses 120 personnes qui
sont absolument exceptionnelles parce
qu'elles n'ont jamais rien lâché et
c'est ça qui est important aussi dans la
vie il croit se battre avec simplicité
proximité humaine volonté et optimiste
c'est ce qu'on ressent ici à
Saint-Quentin pour cette dernière étape
métropolitaine merci Patrice bégaye je
rappelle directeur exécutif de BPI
France le festival des entrepreneurs
vous l'avez compris ça commence
aujourd'hui à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
c'est de 13 heures ouverture du village
jusqu'à 20h avec ce soir en conclusion
un concert des lej et puis et 12 heures
l'arrivée du ministre début de
l'émission à 9h là dans quelques minutes
avec Patrice Bégué qui va recevoir les
entrepreneurs tous les acteurs de 50 ans
en Yvelines le ministre de l'Économie
vous l'avez compris merci suivez-nous
sur le page sur la page facebook sur la
page Twitter sur la page LinkedIn de
tv78 vous allez suivre cette journée sur
nos réseaux sociaux merci et à tout à
l'heure